here comes the money hey what's up my
name is samuel leeds i am a property
investor and i'm standing outside
yet another finished property
development this is in south birmingham
and this was a joint venture agreement
between myself
and my good friend sad hussain was
fifty thousand pounds the renovation was
a hundred and twenty thousand pounds
the current value now is in excess of
three hundred and
seventy thousand pounds so this little
flip
has got a hundred thousand pound profit
in it it was
a little two-bed house now it's a luxury
four bed family home
sad hussain bought the property i put
all the money in
he's given me a fixed return of 14
and i'm really looking forward to seeing
exactly what he's done inside and how
he's managed the refurbishment project
so
let's have a look around let's find out
[Music]
here he is good to see you man
this guy legend nice to see you it's
been a while
come on oh man this looks different
it's a little bit different it's taken
us longer
so uh yeah it's all been stripped back
to brick
and pretty much started again so apart
from the the four
original walls that's all that remains
of the roof
this is fabulous honestly i love the
colors
the the spotlights absolutely fabulous
thank you yeah so this was the first
reception room here we had a lovely
fireplace imagery right down we've
tripled the chimneys out just to try and
give it a little bit more space
yeah it's not a huge house and i think
we're creating that feeling of space is
important because we're just
trying to keep fairly neutral you know
apart from a couple of feature
wallpapers
so yeah you've gone quite high-end with
this
uh yeah i think because we want to
achieve the top price we possibly can
for it it's really
just trying to make it as attractive as
we can to make it look and feel like a
brand new house which is apart from
it it is it's a new build it's a new
build
oh man i can't i don't want to look
because
it will spoil it when you actually show
it but it was a bit of a jungle
previously so what's this
that's a heating system i think that
one's a nest i think it's a nest
yeah uh that one so staircases here
that's been reconfigured a little bit
basement we were originally not going to
use but now we've we've cleared it all
out it's it's dry
heating lighting everything down there
as well now they say that the most
important room in the house
is the kitchen absolutely so you've
really gone over town on the kitchen by
the
looks of things i think we've created a
nice space
lights on so uh this this
this was this ended this ended here i
didn't know
somewhere about here i think yeah ended
here so you've had to build this whole
new extension
yes did this did you need planning
permission did you get permission to do
that yeah
so what we did originally is we uh we
went down both routes simultaneously to
save time so we put planning application
in
and we submitted the committee
development drawings as well essentially
saying look you know if you can give us
planning to do so we're going to do this
if not we're going to do
this bit anyway yeah um and they
declined the planning we could have
actually probably gone back and got it
but
we pushed ahead without them we went
permitted development route so the bit
we didn't get
was to build on top of this part here
okay that's the bit we didn't get so
there would have been another
uh room above here yeah um but we've
effectively built this extension and
converted the loft space with the dormer
okay well it looks
amazing and i think as well with the
kitchen being one of the most important
rooms in the house
the fact that you managed to get
committed development yeah to build this
is a really really good thing if anyone
doesn't know that maybe listening what
is
permitted development development
essentially is
each property has certain rights you're
allowed to change its use do certain
work on it
without submitting a full planning
application yeah so it's looking at what
can we do
via that route because you don't need
any consent of search
just need to know trump is what we're
doing and also looking at planning which
is our more ambitious option
uh and so that way what we've done is
cases we've worked out the maximum we
can do
without actually needing any permission
and we went down that route yeah
which which was your which was your exit
strategy anyway yeah
we talked about this and you said last
year you said we're going to get planned
permission we're going to do this this
and this but if we don't
yeah we're going to get permit
development to do what you've done
so well it looks amazing how much did
this kitchen cost how much was that
actually
you know i don't know exactly how much
we spent but i can assure you it's
nowhere near what you probably think it
is well it looks expensive
so we're trying to just create a really
nice finish
uh i mean these kitchens are magnet
kitchens um
we uh that is like the gloss finish two
tons darker and lighter
and then the the cooker appliances work
top things we just
source from various different suppliers
that we use for our other
uh for our other projects yeah well i
think it's important to make it
do a high-end finish just because if
you're selling it which which you are
you want it to you want it to look like
it's like a show at home
and i think if we think about when we go
to look at a property even as investors
when we're buying
we probably spend 10 maybe 15 minutes in
that house
and we make a decision of 100 to 300 000
pounds
yeah and so i think the detail is
important
so that people's eyes are drawn to
things that are appealing
rather than things that might put them
off yeah yeah so true
this is a great kitchen and i love the
fact that you've just kept it so
open the light i mean it's a really
gloomy day today
but still it feels light and airy what
you've done here is
this is fabulous yeah when we when we
were here last uh
when we were here last looking at the
property it was quite a dark house
yes um i think understatement
it was the middle of the summer last
year july i think when we went when uh
when this happened and it was dreadful
it was it was shabby it was dingy
it was cobwebs everywhere it was just an
absolute
wreck so i was trying to get as much
natural lighting as we can yeah against
the large windows
the skylights as well yeah and the
spotlights as well
and this is really nice over the top on
the spotlights to
really help with your lighting to
brighten it up yeah that's fabulous
all right we'll lead the way sir so
we've got a downstairs red room here
so essentially we've got a bathroom on
each each floor
very nice
so how did you how did you choose all
the different
you know the designs the colors the
patterns did you get yourself into your
interiors
no no we don't use interior designer um
but what we because we've run lots of
projects simultaneously so in fact
when i was doing this one we were
running uh 11 in total houses are
amazing
um so we just take different ideas from
different properties what works well
taking advice like these tiles we don't
use them for the first time we use them
and we use them in i think three before
the houses we've put them in as well
yeah and it's just trying to pick out
things we think will look nice i guess
if we went interior designer would
probably be even better but then also
more expensive
yeah yeah possibly yeah yeah right well
you've done probably thanks we're doing
some new build houses at the moment
we're there
we'll use interior design to stage it
and yeah to finish it
what's it what's in here is this the
basement oh there's a basement down
there yeah
we can we can have a we can have a look
so mind your head is not designed for
tall people
how the family by the way is that yeah
they're all good thank you yes
or oh well i'm busy
i'm quite pleased you can stand up in
here yeah
so this was just unused space now really
it's the case of uh it's just been uh
it's been dried out we've got the
heating of the electrics
and you know we've got plumbing here as
well it's at the end of the day still a
basement we've got a little bit of
natural light and ventilation but
there's always going to be probably a
little bit of damper moisture in
something like this
we could have gone the full route and
tanked it out you've been expensive
not really added enormous amount of
value this way you know it's a hobby
room it's an office utility room
whatever somebody wants to use it for
because it's not a huge house you're
thinking about how can we give somebody
a little bit of extra space
yeah it's really important what you just
said as well about thinking
how much am i going to have to spend and
then what's the added value going to be
and that's i think you need to always
look at that every time you spend a
pound you really want to be adding three
ideally yeah
yeah that's a great way to look at it
because you know there's so many more
things you can do yeah but they're not
necessarily gonna
yeah and if it's your house and you
realize this is not an investment this
is for me
and you can say you know what i want to
do this to the basement yeah but it's
not an investment i just want it but
when it's an investment
yes you need to be looking at the
formulas all the time we've just got
planned permission to build our own
house actually so we're uh
we're going to start congratulations
pretty much and uh
the projects wanted to get a little bit
out of control on that one really yeah
it's all that personal thing about what
these want to create it like this
yeah you don't think about uh what's it
gonna be worth at the end you think
about actually what is it you want
yeah yeah where is that by the way just
near here actually it's not possible
oh good good cool should we go upstairs
yeah
he says i was almost tripped himself i
did the exact same thing
the same step you've gone for
quite luxury carpets yes which i think
is really important because you can
you can ruin a refurb with with bad
carpets definitely a cheap brown carpet
and it's like
i see people sometimes scrimping on
these things and i think it's uh
it has a negative impact yeah when
you're trying to create a premium
product like i said people are going to
be here
only for a few minutes so when they're
walking on a carpet that feels luxurious
that's one less thing they're going to
be thinking about
exactly yeah great this was a room that
was a complete disaster if you remember
previously it was all this was the
cobweb room
the copper rooms are actually the other
one but actually there were cobwebs
everywhere
it was a covered house but this is the
one where these walls fall into pits
because the water's been leaking for
many many years
down here so we've uh kind of gutted it
all out we've done it
we because we're doing this roof anyway
what we've done again we've lifted the
uh
the roof up uh this evening to cover the
ceiling to vault it to give it that more
space uh feeling of space and more light
as well yeah
so talk talk to me about the about the
about the cost of the
of the development because i know that
initially it was a 120
120 000 pound which to be fair seemed
quite a lot
yeah over at first but then when you
find out what you're actually going to
do and the fact that we're going to be
building and
extending um did it come on budget did
it
we did go over a little bit so 130
okay which is bad yeah yes i'm still i'm
still quiet
yeah i mean what what was probably more
painful with the time frame
because we were running so many
different projects at the same time and
then we ran into lockdown and issues of
materials trying to get them
and not all the trades people being
available and all these things caused
quite a bit of slowdown but i guess the
advantage that we've had during that
time is the price has been continuing
yeah so that that's sort of my happening
yeah i was going to ask about that so
the how
it was a one 150 purchase price 120 as
it happens 1 30 but i put in 120
um for the for the refurb so all in
talking 272 ac um
what what do we think the value is now
probably at least 100 grand more than
that
at least 100 grand more so that's
probably quite a bit more
yeah well well it's um it's on the
market now for what around
around the 400 miles yeah close up so
we're looking for offers around that
sort of around about 400
so fingers crossed yeah i'm quite
confident we'll get it yeah budget
because
i know it's not been on the market long
have you had much interest um so
initially we tested it at a slightly
higher price
yeah um and we had some interest but now
enough so now what we've flipped it and
gone uh at a much lower figure but
offers over
to get the interest in and i'm quite
sure we will get it shifted in a few
weeks
great awesome and and what caused do
they you see
was it a combination of it other
projects yeah i mean because running so
many different projects
as well at the same time that's been one
of the uh issues
um the uh the biggest problem we've had
on most of the sites is trying to get
materials
yeah there's been a lack of materials in
space i like for example you can't get
plastic you can't really progress with
the project they're just growing to a
halt yeah
and then sometimes my builders say in
the same way that we
uh we normal people save up toilet roll
they're storing the plaster you know
because it it is it's running out it is
slowing things down but
you've done a fabulous finish and i
don't think it's going to be crazy last
year
when we started so yeah it's gone over a
little bit but um
you know these things happening yeah
yeah i mean uh
say two things to learn about um about
projects
uh they take longer and cost more yeah
often
they need to build that in me yeah yeah
but this is part of it and
you know you're very experienced so
luckily this
this property there's enough profit in
there yeah and that's i think that's the
real key as well if you've got a
property whereby you've only got
20 30 grand profit yes and then you go
over you're stuffed but when you've got
a hundred thousand pounds more
plus profit in the deal you might go
over ten thousand pounds but it's not
stopping you it's not scavenger
absolutely and i think for me the the
key aspect is
having deals that have significant
profit in them yes they take
longer to find there's not many of them
as around but actually that means that
everybody makes money so you know on
this project
talk about previously that actually you
know all of your money's gone into it
you've led the money for the project
uh somebody else sourced it and built
him and managed it i've been here
periodically just making sure
ultimately i'm responsible for it but as
long as i know there's enough profit in
it it doesn't matter if things cost
a little bit more it goes over a little
bit it's still going to work for
everybody
great so so true all right let's see
what's next cool
let's go on through so this this room is
the uh the middle bedroom we were in the
rear bedroom just now
good sizes yeah i mean here uh if you
remember we had some
um 70s fitted uh shelves and cupboards
and wardrobes which were taking the
chimney breasts out as well again as we
said just
just to make the house uh and uh the
rooms
more uh feel more spacious as well so
they're more usable they're more
practical
when these houses were built it was it
was built for a completely different
area and people lived in a different way
so it's thinking about how can we make
this
comfortable desirable for a family that
want to live in it today
yeah yeah you know what as well the two
things that you can't change
you'll know this size and location so
you chose a property in a prime location
big old property and then what you've
done is you've transformed it into
something that's beautiful that's modern
looks like a show home
and that's why you've added so much
value so yeah really good and i can
remember it before and it's a different
house
a totally different house this is the
the main bedroom at the front of the
house
this one is the one i was walking into
cobwebs last time
oh yeah um and here what we've done
we've got an ensuite
uh in this uh this room so it's still a
good size
um again we've removed the the chimney i
can't remember where the chimney was on
this one i think it was on that side so
the chimney breast
is gone so again nice and spacious we've
got two big windows
um it feels like a nice spacious room
and someone like quite tall much taller
than me
may not even realize actually we've
dropped the ceilings uh we've lowered
them and the reason we've lowered them
because we wanted to create more head
height
in the loft so that was going to be more
spacious because if we can drop the
ceilings a little bit
actually it means you can walk further
in the loft towards the eaves
which actually makes quite a significant
difference to um
to the loft good job and you've added
quite a lot of ensuite you added a
toilet downstairs
yeah and again that's another thing
about new homes people
in 2020 they want lots of bathrooms lots
of toilets yes if you've got four or
five people living in the house you
probably want
at least three toilets yeah if you've
got a four bedroom house
you know it's going to be uh probably
mom and dad the kids
you've got to think about how is it
going to work for everybody yeah
today and that's why um i think
emphasizing on
how are people going to use the house
and how can you make it
as desirable as comfortable as possible
that's what that's what was uh
is going to sell it yeah great job what
was the loft before what was it like was
it
just a loft there was nothing there it
was a very small loft because you've
added
yeah you've added one there was actually
a
cupboard here yeah and that was it so
this is all being uh built as new in
fact the whole staircase in the house is
new but that's
what we've created here so this isn't
really a refurb this is definitely a
proper
renovation this is a development so here
we've got uh
probably the biggest room in the house
yeah nice and spacious
it's a good room and so that the bit
where you're standing now that's a
dormer at the rear
so the house literally would have
probably the loft would have ended about
here
so that's stretched out means it just
gives it a lot more space yeah
we've got a bathroom on this floor as
well and the space behind it rather than
allow it to just go to waste we just use
it as storage
and by lowering the ceilings uh in the
rooms below
actually what it means is you can walk
further this way so it actually
makes the room uh makes the room a lot
bigger yeah that makes sense
yeah because if the ceiling if the
ceiling was a bit higher you wouldn't be
able
to get out from standing here yeah yeah
great
i don't know if you remember the garden
samuel probably can't see so well here
yeah i remember it yeah through the rain
it was a bit of a jungle yeah
so it looks a little bit different it
looks fabulously
and just again uh little things like
we're actually backing onto several
different gardens
so that means there's actually lots of
different
um fence panels that were there but
although most of these weren't has we
replaced them all
anyway just to make it look much more
attractive
yeah and it's a small cost it's one of
those isn't it it's like
you could think oh i don't that's not my
fence defense i'm not going to fix it
but then actually
then you end up with a nasty looking
fence yeah so we've done a little bit of
work in most of the neighbors gardens as
well
um just to to make uh it work for us
and it keeps the neighbors happy what
have you done in the neighbor's garden i
thought we've got rid of uh
hedges bushes we've refitted the fences
for them we've cleared up a little bit
of stuff on the side of theirs because
we had a few
there were large trees on the side and
although they weren't in our
property yeah they were affecting the
property so negotiating neighbors
getting them taken down somewhere
it's funny because my mom used to always
say to me when we were looking to move
house she'd say
do i know what the area is like look at
the neighbors gardens
yes and if the neighbor's gardens are
terrible then that probably is not a
great neighbor so what you've done is
you've been like
i'm going to fix up their gardens yeah
so
again when someone's looking there it
just looks nicer it feels nice and
attractive all the neighbors are happy
because
you know let's face it you know doing
work like this is quite disruptive for
the neighbors as well
yeah and the neighbor on this side been
great we've done little bits of work for
him as well
again it just means that they're on side
um they're happy
uh it costs us very little because we're
here anyway we've got trades but anyway
whether it's a few extra fence panels or
it's a lick of paint or something it's
of a negligible cost to us
yeah and it's great when you've got
people on side as well neighbors the
community with them on site it makes a
big difference
absolutely yeah good job there fantastic
so here we have the other
bathroom on the uh on the top floor this
is essentially the main main bathroom if
you like
or the one the bathtub and
again we've kind of squeezed it into
that space although
it doesn't feel like it's been so nice
it's actually a pretty big
bath yeah so yeah you've done so well
and i think you've used the space that
you've got really really effectively
yeah fabulous job yeah i think they're
very modern again wow thank you
i think spending a lot of time at the
beginning in terms of how the house is
going to be laid out exactly where
is going to go for example p-shaped bath
day it was an afterthought
it was all created in the initial plans
and although we spend a lot more time
there it just means then it's really
about just managing
the managing the uh the works and not
have to worry about the detail
and oh as an afterthought maybe we
should put this here we should put that
there
there's less of those things there's
always going to be some little bits of
detail that you'll find along the way
maybe it might be better to do this way
or we change that
that you find as you're going through
the project but the more you plan
beforehand the easier it is
yeah you know what i'm really impressed
about as well the photos
look incredible talk to me about that
because i know you have a thing about
photos so tell me
yeah so these are lots of little things
we learned over the years as we've been
as we've been doing this
is an agent will say yeah we'll take the
photographs i'll be professional
photographs
they might be or they may not be so
great so i don't take that chance what i
do is we have our professional
property photographer he takes all the
photos and we send them to the agent say
these are the ones you're going to use
you'll never do a good of a job when
it's not your properties
so what you know you i know if you're
anything like me sad to your team
they'll be like on a ladder really far
back trying to make the kitchen look as
big as possible
but uh the pictures are fabulous online
so
whatever it was makes a huge difference
in terms of
it comes back down to that people are
going to make decisions very quickly
based on their feelings their emotion
yeah and if
the pictures look great if it feels
great when they're coming they don't see
anything that they need to change or
things that don't look right that all
helps in terms of the buying process
this was before it was just
overgrown yeah it was a jungle it's
quite a jungle here
and although it's a small garden it's
again just trying to make it
as usable as practical as possible what
did you do yeah so we've just turfed
this here
everything everything's got to be quick
this was literally within 10 days it was
starting to uh
to grow so we've cut it i think twice
since it was uh done it looks like it's
ready for another
another cut and again the outside
just talk to me a little bit about what
happened on the outside yeah i mean i
guess
the rendering is probably uh not quite
as perfect as i would like it but it's
it's good enough
uh for for for the job that we're doing
at the end of day it's an old house
as well that we're modernizing but it
just uh it
it had cladding on before which was
really horrible saw the cladding come
off we thought we might be able to
restore the bricks but that wasn't
really going to be visible it looks good
it looks like a new build which is what
you've gone for the whole thing
looks like a brand new property if you
if you didn't know any better you'd
think
you'd literally smash the whole thing
down and build it again from scratch
yeah
most of your deals that you do you
always seem to do them in forms of joint
ventures
like why is that i guess when i started
from about around 15 years ago i started
to have any money
and i just got really good at finding
deals but then i realized actually
sourcing is not going to
pay me very well for the rest of my life
and i just by accident started
partnering with other people using other
people's money
on deals and i thought this is a much
better way to go and i just continued
doing that
so that that's really how it hadn't
started by accident
you know what it's interesting that you
said you started deal sourcing
and i always say that when you start
maybe you should maybe you should start
deal sourcing for free
just to prove your credibility then
start charging then start charging more
then start joint venturing and you just
build it up and i think one of the
reasons i
um joint ventures with sad is because
he's got credibility
you know we're good friends we've been
friends for we've known each other for
years now quite a few years
and um if you're putting your money into
someone's deal make sure that not only
is the deal good but also know how to
charge on this property of course
but also make sure that the the person's
good they know what they're doing
so uh you know you've done a cracking a
crapping job oh thank you very much i
really appreciate it
it's gone seamlessly working with you as
well so you know that's been great yeah
you know what
when you told me about the deal it was
just immediate wasn't it yeah within a
few days we'd kind of when i mentioned
it we'd met up we had a chat we looked
at the property within days
we had it done and we had it that's what
you have to do
speed is important if a good deal comes
along you need to be able to see a good
deal you need to be able to make a
decision that's what
sage did that's what i did on this
project and um you know it's been great
seeing it again i hope you guys enjoy it
this dude's amazing check him out i'll
leave a link in the description for sag
also if you want to do development deals
like this says what about the top piece
of advice you'd give to someone wanting
to step out and do an investment i think
you've got to find an amazing deal
yes if you find really good deals you
don't worry about finding the money the
money will find you
absolutely i think that's key and then
having right people on board in terms of
contractors
um and architects people working with to
do risk as much as you possibly can
yeah you know what if you've got good
deals sad you're so right if you've got
good deals
the money will come to you so if you
want to learn how to find good deals
you can do that by getting trained and
i'm going to leave again i'm going to
leave more videos where you can get
trained on how to find good deals
if you've got money and you're looking
to invest in deals have a conversation
find people that are doing deals have a
conversation it's all about taking
action and that's the biggest thing
i'm going to shoot such pleasure see you
see that god bless you thank you so much
peace out bye now thank you so much for
watching guys i hope you enjoyed it
you can check out all of my videos
honestly
get good at finding deals the money will
come to you i promise you also if you've
got
money but you haven't got time and you
want to invest into someone else's deals
let's have a chat and i look forward to
helping you succeed in property
see you next time